[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
always makes me feel good love that what
a jingle right oh guys
today i have one of the greatest lads on
the podcast
he's a hawksbay legend he's won the
super rugby
with the hurricanes and now he's a very
popular figure over in japan
and he's even recently been called into
the japanese international training
squad
as well as that he's been a huge part of
the great
hurricanes info committee and of course
he is an absolute lad it is one of the
great
mark abbott welcome jared great to be
here jared you know one of the great
chaps i'm full of confidence now let's
go let's get into it
mate that is that is a good response i'm
really feeling
energetic now so because you are one of
the great jareds
i'm one of many jared's mate um any
jared who
asked why you're a jab becomes a jared
and there's jared's and several
countries around the world mate
who's your favorite jared oh my big
japanese made over here
takashi genki um he's a great jared
what about jared broadhurst he's the
original jared isn't he big joe
broadhurst um the big grump also
favorite
so many so many jared's and have you
named your child jared
i haven't got a child yet but um
hopefully we'll have one soon and
potentially could be called jared
i hope they're called jared they'll be
one of the greats
anyway what are you up to what are you
up to over there mate i am sitting in my
tatami room with my
beautiful bamboo floor here uh in
munakata in japan just taking it easy
and season's finished how was how was
the year with xanax uh
season has finished three weeks ago it
was
not a champagne season for sanix
unfortunately we had a
tough road games there but um we're
doing all the same
it's been probably fair to say you've
had a pretty tough run since you've been
over in japan
haven't won a huge amount of games have
you i had a funny dream the other day
and i was talking to someone and saying
that
since i left the hurricanes i've won
four games
that meant anything um so four games in
four years has been
it's been challenging mate it's been
challenging what was that the dream
or like i was speaking to someone but
then i woke up and i was like well
speaking the truth wasn't it
you've actually only won four games in
three years
yeah two were sanics one with the sun
wolves one with coke and drew one with
coke as well to save from relegation so
it was um
you know yeah i mean i had a few
injuries i missed a couple of games here
but here and there but
yeah it just makes those ones that much
sweeter you know like if you want it
every week you but over it sometimes but
when you get that one win after 17 games
i'll tell you what mate it's
it's sweet it's party time
and how was it at xenox have you enjoyed
the move i uh
i've actually really loved it out here
so we are
about 45 minutes out of the city so it's
a little bit more rural
um if anywhere in japan is rural but um
you know rice paddies
along the road to training um and get
out there and
the training grounds right next to the
beach just swim after every train it's
just yeah it's beautiful really enjoyed
that here
well that's good to hear in the club
how's the club going because there's
been some rumors floating around
yeah so unfortunately sanex has decided
to
i assume pull back the budget um and
and focus on i assume other areas of the
business but so the rugby team is
downsizing quite a bit
so yeah the foreign numbers um foreign
player numbers and coaching staff is
is going to be as low for the yeah next
few years or so so what does that mean
for the club
so yeah i mean over here is japan a lot
of people will say like
the bigger your budget the better you'll
go um and i'm not going to sling any mud
but if you look at someone like
team like kobe um well they were strong
enough mid-table but
a couple years ago the side just put a
lot of money into it and obviously
buying daniel carter is a good start
um and then you know they won the
championship final by 40 points so
it just shows you what you can do if
you've got money um sanix being a
smaller club with not a lot of money
um to throw around has always originally
struggled and so
with this even greater decrease in
funding yeah it's going to be harder for
them to compete in those
echelons of top league rugby over here
yeah so they're going to drop down
so yeah my understanding is that yeah
they're going to drop down
a division or maybe two but
a lot of these conversations sometimes
happen in japanese and although i've
been here a few years i can't understand
everything so
fair enough and obviously there's some
pretty sad news about our other
team the coca-cola red sparks last week
how they've pulled pin on their
rugby program all together yeah that was
absolutely devastating to here to be
honest
from what i understand the boys didn't
have a clue and they went into a meeting
expecting just to be told what's
happening and like going forward and
the big bosses were like that's it
we're done no more on our ugly team so
obviously the foreign boys with families
over here it's quite stressful but
for the japanese boys that means
literally no more rugby
unless they find another team but most
of them just go back to full-time jobs
it's sad hey because there's some really
good players in that team and to think
that they're now
no longer going to be playing rugby it
feels like a real waste
yeah it is it's a it's a big waste and
there's guys like
my favorite japanese player um yusaku
kuazuru he was mr sevens japan sevens
captain for a long time
you know he's given 16 17 years to that
team
and you know he still had more gas in
the tank and
he just loved it and then to see him
retire on the back of this has been
yeah it's been yeah pretty hard pretty
hard to watch so what's stopping someone
like him going to another team can you
do you understand all that
oh well he was a professional um so he
was
able to go to another team oh yeah um
but
in that space you know he's 36 or seven
i'm not going to remember but yeah
once you get to that age it's a bit
harder to transition to other teams he's
got family here that's
you know his kids are in school it's
just hard to move around so yeah i mean
obviously the young boys who are up and
coming want to have a crack by all means
seek out new teams but yeah the older
guys not not so easy so do you have to
go to professional to change teams or no
not that i am aware of so it's difficult
because like coca-cola by working there
being a half half a part-time part-time
worker
you have a job for life yeah which is
great security for these boys so
when they you know rugby's pulled up
stumps them here
um they can choose to go to another team
but then they forego that
job for life and and you know coca-cola
is a huge company and there's a lot of
you know opportunity there for them
yeah challenging challenging stuff for
them i tell you what
and obviously the foreigners the ones
that we played with over there they'll
be
they'll be in a bit of a difficult
situation they'll be scrambling around
for clubs too and there's some good
players there
um who could be a good pick up for some
teams looking yeah absolutely so
obviously with cynics and coke both
downsizing
and i hear there's a little bit going on
another team in tokyo um
a low ranked team but you know that's
kind of
three teams that would take a lot of
foreigners you know and
now that market becomes more compressed
and there's less opportunity out there
so
those guys are i'm hopeful they'll pick
up you know gigs here and there but it's
um yeah it's a bit of a challenging way
to go we've got a family
yeah that relies on you is it worrying
times for japanese rugby you reckon or
is this
sort of a one-off potentially because
this is my limited knowledge of it but
and i don't want to offend anyone but
from what i understand the corporate
rugby over here is
obviously governed by the jr a few but
the companies have a lot of power
and so it's been like that for a long
time for as long as the leg's been in
action
and with this transition to a pro league
from what i understand there's a quite a
hefty financial
burden to to bear to be part of that
league
and some teams who aren't the big budget
teams are potentially thinking
maybe not not for us or maybe we'll go
in a different direction
so i don't know if it's a bad sign for
japanese rugby because i think
as a whole this new pro league will
probably make the game stronger over
here
and make it more professional and you
know play welfare will be a bigger thing
which we
yeah should be really good for them it
will be a good thing
because it hasn't been a lot of that
nice
almost non-existent but hey
but anyway something that's happened the
last few weeks
you your form has been so good that
you've been called into the japanese
training squad how good is that yeah i
mean my form on
on just training in general must have
been pretty good because i had i've
missed a few games jimmy i had a few
injuries so
um apparently they like the way i get on
the road and
go to work so you were always good on
the bike out of the saddle you could
bike for hours
jared i loved i loved the ladder and you
know i took the win for
cali and um surf to peak a few years ago
a few times so yeah
i don't mind the bike but no like really
excited to be part of the
japan squad um like since the world cup
and even before that since i got here i
saw that team and
i liked the way they played it was
exciting and look like they're having a
lot of fun and
um everyone gets on really well i was
like yeah i'd really like to be
a part of that if i could you know if i
could make it become eligible so
i've hopefully taken the first step and
now it's up to me just to
you know perform and to end up no doubt
you'll do that so how did the how did
the call come about did jamie joe call
you or
what happened there well it's 2021 james
so i got an email which was um
which was great yeah uh yeah just
asking if i was interested and i said
100 i'm interested
um and then that was a couple weeks
before the team was announced and then
the team was announced and and that was
great and all exciting and that was
where it's been left at the moment but
i'm
sure to get some information soon
you're probably supposed to be at kemp
last week
well i'm not sure i've been ringing a
few people knowing it seems to answer so
maybe it was a typo or something
that is weird that way just hair food
nothing yeah oh
i think i think there's a fair bit going
on with world rugby schedules and
calendars and i don't know if there's
actually
as much information available as you'd
probably expect so
yeah yeah oh fair enough but how's your
japanese and stuff anyway i know it was
you were getting better while i was over
there but you must be pretty fluent now
now you're a japanese international
influencer yeah it's a loose word to
throw to
my situation mate but i go through
phases of trying really really hard and
i'll study every day and
have my lessons and stuff and then and
then i'll just stop for a wee while and
yeah yeah but it's one of those
situations where like
i wanted to learn it to be able to just
have conversations with the boys with
the teammates to
get to know each other because it's
really hard like you can't just bring
your translator along to coffee every
time you take you know go out with
someone
so yeah yeah and it's getting there i
don't know
are you trying that are you at that
point where you can go for a coffee now
with a japanese guy
who can't speak english yeah i think so
like i've been for
dinner with a couple of boys like and
with their bit of english with my little
bit of japanese we kind of get there a
little bit of google translate yeah yeah
have a few faux pas but that's a bit of
fun
and one more thing about the japanese
can you sing the national anthem
um i've actually been told that i should
definitely learn that
yeah um before i even get close to
potentially getting on the field one day
yeah um so
i've i've actually put that on the to-do
list yeah this week so
so you don't know it yet can't get away
reading
go on give us a wee something no
honestly
[Laughter]
maybe i'll just reserve that until like
if i'm actually selected and
you know fingers crossed in that
department then and then really just
cram it all in at the end there
oh because you do have a good voice i
always loved listening to you at karaoke
that's not true it's not true man
that's auto-tune t-pain just that
yeah actually t-pain has a delightful
voice i heard it recently oh it doesn't
have a live view
he's unbelievable what without
auto-change yeah it's almost like why
didn't you
perform your whole career with without
it it was really good what was he in
japan
oh i wish no um i don't know where i
heard it one of those
yeah live studio things doesn't mean i
thought you saw him live oh no okay oh
that's cool
no because you do do a lot of travel
though
and you have definitely made the most of
your travel while you've been over there
haven't you
yeah so that was actually mainly the
reason i came over here while
me and my wife came over was just to
experience something different
something new and with the new zealand
rugby schedule we get a very small
window
um of time off and in that time off you
could also
remain fit to turn up and shape so
coming over here the attraction was that
there's
large amounts of time off off seasons
and fireworks and stuff so whenever we
had a chance we were
pre-covered we were out of there gone
a few places mate yeah any favorites
because you saw
pretty much half the world and i
remember you going for a massive holiday
it must have been like three months or
something was it
am i making that up yeah we have a
couple well
we spent a couple of months in south
america last year yeah
well however it worked out yeah like for
the well definitely a honeymoon but no i
was actually here before um
yeah it was just great mate like getting
out and getting a bit intrepid and
getting away from footy for a bit and
you know didn't have to do any training
for
six or eight weeks and then just gives
it the body of time to
repair and you know feel a bit better
about things and you can actually
turn back up and be really hungry ready
to go you know you have been living so
go on give give me your favorite holiday
spot for when covert ends and we can go
back on the airplane where are we going
oh probably your house of math well mate
[Laughter]
yeah every day is a holiday out here
what a spot
absolutely um now
i was really keen to go to mongolia last
year just to um
just looks absolutely wild and just out
of it and want to try it out but
yeah i mean maybe in a year or two so we
see how we end up not sure yet fair
enough mongolia let's put it on the
cards
yeah i heard when the honey badge was
over here playing for coke he nipped off
for a bye week and went
um was it hawking or eagling oh yeah
what is that they hunt with them to do
it
anyway mate we've gone a long way
through and we haven't even gone back to
the start for you one of my favorite
parts of the podcast is getting to know
what life was like for you growing up so
what was life for the young
little jared like in christchurch
because i know you're a big christchurch
man
yeah um life is pretty good mate
simple life well i grew up in darfield
so i said 35 minutes outside of
christchurch
on a farm it's the youngest of four kids
so i had it pretty easy um not gonna lie
um yeah farm life was good the older
brothers were
i don't know maybe a bit a little bit
sick of me when i was constantly
following me around
probably idolized them when i was a kid
um
that night was good and then went from
darfield high school into boarding
school
that's andrew's in christchurch and yep
so i spent
five years boarding which was just great
mate just living with your best mates
highly recommend it and then then when i
left school i did a gap year in uk which
another thing i'd highly recommend if
people are able to do it just great to
get that
independence and coach a bit of footy
and
do a bit of travelling and drink a few
beers it was here was all the time where
did you go
i went to sutton balance school which is
in like uh
it's in kent so just south of london oh
yeah yeah and so i spent
my days geez it was gentlemanly i think
we started at nine
and finished at maybe 3 30. yeah and i
was just in the pe department just
teaching helping out with pe and then
when there wasn't a class i'd just
get like the trampoline out or get the
bowling machine out and face a few balls
like it was just
that was great man so good
and obviously at your age you would have
been having a few big nights over there
in london
as a young christchurch man must have
had a few good stories from
those times by anyone that's spent time
over in london
at that age um and in the past enough
it's still there but the
the church was an absolute institution
frequented a few times and yeah it was
i don't know how to describe just
departures it was
scratched up that's a good word um yeah
there's no other way to describe it like
that is what it is and it's
famous for that so you just embrace it
it's not it's not going anymore is that
i don't think so eh yeah i think it
might have moved on but
it was good while it lasted as with a
lot of things yeah so then what was
after the um gap year
i returned to christchurch
and i started university at canterbury
played my footy for christchurch
football club battled through some cults
and a bit of prem's there
and then i was in the academy there for
a couple of years
yeah um they'd only keep players for
three years i think
and after my second year i had got
caught into
the academy manager's office office and
he was like
look mate we are not going to take you
through the next year in the academy
and i was like okay that's fair enough
what have you done well probably not
enough made by the senator
were you a good trainer though i always
yeah i mean you've always been a good
trainer hard worker since
i've known you so were you the same back
then or were you just right into your
purse
um no no i wasn't around my person
i probably um obviously tried my hardest
but
at that age i probably just thought
there was a path to follow so
yeah you know i made the academy and the
natural progression of that was
into playing for canterbury and then
play for candy play for crusaders like
just yeah i was probably a little bit
naive in terms of
this with the path i thought it would
follow um and then so for him to tell me
that
that was not my path and he said you
know go and do this you you know you
might end up
somewhere else and i was like okay um so
i played a year of cults with
craig philpot was the head coach there
at canterbury yeah kenneth colts and he
had moved up to cooke's bay so
i uh i gave him a call one day and i
said mate are you looking for any
players up there and he said i i am for
sure
we'd be great to have you up here mate i
can't offer you a contract or anything
but we can get you up here and you know
you can
play club rugby and try and crack it
that way yeah
and i said well that's good enough for
me mate so i picked up my 96 nissan blue
bed
with zero hubcaps and just
driving up there and just ripped into my
work really yeah
jeez i i honestly thought you went up
there with the contract i can't believe
that
that's good stuff nah mate like so i
thought my carp my golf clubs took a bit
of space i always liked my golf
um and rolled up there and i was like i
heard from a mate and he put it in
pretty in simple terms he said
you know if you put yourself in a
situation where the only
option is to succeed then you you're
more likely to succeed does that make
sense so
by going up there i put myself in a
situation where it's like well this has
to work otherwise
hey it's a little bit embarrassing um
because you come back to christchurch
between your legs two degree um and b
you know like
this is what you really want you gotta
you gotta give it everything you know
otherwise
you just you know just fade out and
it'll be the end of it so
yeah there's some there's funny old
times up there like when i
when i rolled into napier i had yeah my
car and i pulled up to
i was living at a yeah it's like a
separate granny flat attached to nick
mclennan's
house he was already up there and uh in
my house i had
a tv on the ground i had a camp chair
and a black mattress i lived on a black
mattress for like six months oh
wow that is humble
but it was like i don't know quite enjoy
today well i didn't have tv so i had
like a
hard drive um with a few tv shows on it
so
when like movies and i'd watch like an
hour of a movie a night and go to bed
and
um yeah it was it was humble but it was
yeah it was good i really enjoyed it
fond memories made fun memories let's go
and you obviously got stuck into your
work you must have had an outstanding
club
season because you were into the hawke's
bay side straight away is that right
yeah so i don't really know where i sit
you know so i went up there as a number
eight
slash blind side um that may cover lock
um but yeah after playing
the majority club season i called in one
day and said you know we went through a
contract
and i said oh great and he said would
you be interested in two years i was
like
would i um so jump that chance
um maybe a little bit premature but you
know
if that's something you've been wanting
you take what you can get so yeah i mean
i don't remember planning the greatest
for them in life but it must be the
right and then
um grant derns was the trainer he was
training us hard and i probably got as
fit as i've
ever been at that stage in my life and
yeah i think
that's translated through into itunes
cup like and it's probably sat with me
most of my career mate like i i feel
like i play my best footy when i'm like
really fit yeah so i don't know some
people
do other things other ways but like i
feel that gives me
i just feel like i'm more in the game
and more accurate get to more places do
more things it's just
yeah it's pretty simple philosophy so
like i've learned that lesson
well i didn't learn in it but i lint and
hawke's bay and it served me pretty well
so far
yeah no doubt look at you now how good
so what was it like going into that
hawke's bay and
uh set up well there's some living
legends there carl lowe one of the
greats
new co-man oh he was there
one of the greatest dirt bags you ever
made no great guy love him
um yeah mate like he rolled into that
team and
um albe matthewson was there and i'm
sitting there going
there's some pretty pretty big dogs here
and
yeah yeah like somehow i got thrown in
the cold face of buddy as a lock and
must have played alright in the first
couple of games and
and then i got a call from hammer one
day and he's like mate
i'm gonna come to hawke's bay to have a
auntie if you can
but maybe join the hurricanes i was like
you're probably having a laugh but
you're going there mate
yeah i mean it happened a hell of a lot
faster than i thought it would um
yeah it was yeah bloody exciting time to
tell you what so was it straight up
was it after your first year with
hawke's bay you got that call from
hammer
five games i think oh wow jeez instantly
yeah
yeah i don't know what's going on maybe
he's
seen something that some other people
weren't before that but
no matter like obviously very grateful
to um
epoxy and then obviously the hammer and
stuff for giving me the chance and
and you know giving you that confidence
to know that you
yeah maybe you do actually belong to
that level you know yeah and you
obviously had a couple of
tough finishes to your years first two
years at hawke's bay losing a couple
of finals was it
a couple of touches oh i still remember
them so well mate like
we what was it you hired to click to win
against tasman in
2013. a tough kick mate and he gave it a
pretty good nudge it just
wasn't straight enough were you feeling
confident when he was lining it up did
you think it was
he was going to get it i mean he can
kick mate like he's
his gun so i was like it could be on
here
and obviously didn't work out and then
the ruthless marco supporters and
there's
god i love him just giving it to him
after like you effed up
yeah i was like hey you won the game do
you need to like
just absolutely trade god ever yeah so
that was that was a tough one and then
the following year we did
everything the same and then got yeah i
think we got
pretty well beaten by a man or two in
the final again
um obviously being our next door
neighbors it's always a bit of a sour
contest you know so
they look like a good occasion too
though obviously the smaller regions
when they're hosting finals always seems
to bring some good energy
oh 100 like to be honest with you i've
got a lot of friends in that uh two team
and like
i was as happy for them you know as much
as i like you know would have liked to
won it like it was
it was awesome that a small team like
that won it and got promoted and
yeah and what not and then i think they
got relegated the
following year anyway and you guys got
to win it the following year was that
right
third time lucky we third time lucky
mate we
had yeah we had wellington at home and
it must have been
i think it was 25 24 or something that
was he has an absolute nail biter
got a w there and the boy's bloody
ripped in like well obviously we lost
the shield
two weeks before that so that was a bit
sad but then this
this tastes a bit better
how was that do you do well it was the
one you won way better than the ones you
lost or was it all pretty much
well they're all pretty good dudes oh
chris eaton runs a great cup
uh cordy mate um yeah they were
they're always just fantastic
and what about with the shield was it
the same when you won the shield or
had that sort of tapered off because who
was it was it mu talking about
three day turnaround or something and
they still got absolutely hammered
before they lost it the following the
following week were you involved then
i don't really remember much that game
but i remember the feeling after winning
that shield in dunedin and it was just
the greatest feeling like
yeah pretty satisfying like just yeah
unbelievable
and the boys it was a sunday and we
absolutely lost the plot
um in dunedin which is easy to do
and then it couldn't quite turn up
against counties the following week but
it was a great six days or whatever
while at last
so good but you guys hawke's bay seem to
get shield challenges at least once or
twice a year
they love the shield yeah i don't know
who's doing it i don't know he's doing
the schedules but he clearly works for
hawke's bay which is great
i think tasman have had two or three
since they've started like
maybe two from ever in their whole
entire history of the region
unbelievable
unbelievable yeah that shield is just
it's a glorious thing that like
gets around like hawke's bay is great at
showing it to everyone in every school
and yeah everyone gets a part of which
is awesome oh it is a good thing and
then
talk to me about your hurricane's uh
career going into the hurricanes
environment how was that
obviously happened pretty quickly yeah
it happened quickly um
similar situation you know you're
walking walking day one and like
your lockers next to jeremy thrash and
dane coles and you're like
a couple of absolute greats what was it
like um
being next to dane cole's in the locker
room people i'm sure a lot of people
want to does he give you a niggle in the
locker room
he was he's just a negative guy isn't he
like he's from um
you know he's from pram so he's always
going to be a nugget guy
and even in the locker room mate he's
pushing and shoving you know it's just a
bit of fun you're like come on don't
grow up mate
you're 30 years old mate you've got kids
just come on
he's actually a lovely guy it's really
nice guy
but but i think there's so many people
out there that look at cole's even going
but if they don't know him they're like
oh he's just oh he loves the [ __ ] but
when he's on your team
you love that he loves the [ __ ] you get
[Laughter]
what was he like having next year these
two guys have obviously both come on
waterloo before so it's good to get some
insight onto them from someone else's
perspective
thruster a lot of energy love them um
mate i learned a lot from thrashing two
years ahead with him there like
it was just great to mirror him and
watch him and just see what he does and
you know pick up little things um
i remember i remember my
super every debut was yeah first game of
the year against the sharks at the shark
tank in durban
reasonably daunting task for a young
fella
and we had a line out session somewhere
during the week and i've been out
doing what you're doing durbin you'd go
shark diving or playing golf or whatever
you did
that's another story in itself that was
one of the worst trips ever
yeah that was a couple years later yeah
we'll get into that in a second but i
think we
played golf we came back we just did
this like walk through line out session
and like obviously i started with thrush
and
you know i'd take chance and like i
stuffed up a couple of the calls
yeah then afterwards he like gets the
boys in and just absolutely
blasts us as a collective but purely
directed at me
and i say okay i learned my lesson here
like
that's the expectation i know now yeah
so yeah that was good it's good to learn
early on
yeah gotta have someone tell you tell
you the truth hey but let's let's
talk to me about that shark diving
experience what was that like for you
because i've got a great photo of you
deep under the water with big big sharks
swimming around you it's one of the
great photos
oh mate look
whatever we drove like if i remember
right about two hours south
uh to this reasonably dodge elephant
port and you jump on this boat
and there's like waves crashing and he's
just waiting he's waiting and he just
fangs in this like fiberglass oversized
dinghy
and you're like this can't be right and
he just cruises well he cruises out
over far half an hour so and then he
stops and his other boats around and
like
okay sweet so obviously no cage which
was we'd agreed to
sign the waivers and whatnot and then
you're like oh yeah sweet
so i'm gonna jump in there and then i'm
all good and then you start seeing the
fins like
touching the surface you're like am i
all good like
honestly thought as i sitting on the
side of the boat i was like
what have i done in my life to end up at
this point where i'm about to
jump into shark infested waters like
why am i doing this were you seasick
like everyone else or were you all right
because i remember everybody
was spewing and i was i was the only one
that was all right
we're only in the water for half an hour
so but i just remember like
i think maddie proctor went first i
didn't know you might have been second
and then fats lasted a while and then he
was chumming up but honestly by the end
of it i was the only one left and i was
swimming around it was just like
little bits of meat like white rice
floating
this is no good the boys are absolutely
foul
that was crap
oh one of the great traps
ulta oh i can't believe you didn't get
sick what a what a sailor
oh iron stomach mate that's what they
call me over here do they
you never smell it i was gonna say
you're always spewing on the pass
[Laughter]
what about your other another thing that
i remember about you
obviously at the hurricanes is your info
committee
you were recruited in your very first
year at the hurricanes
the best signing potentially of all time
for the info committee
any good memories from your times in
that community obviously
one of the greatest honors of my life um
obviously sits above uh marrying my wife
you know winning the ramp for this year
winning super rugby like all those power
in comparison to
you know the initial signing into the
info committee i was very stoked you
know it's a
prestigious committee um you know we did
a lot of work you know we were
i don't know how you put it we were the
we were the
team barometer you know like yeah anyone
got a little bit out of hand you just
wiped them down a couple bit of subtle
humour um
potentially sometimes went a bit far and
probably not so pc but
um yeah it was it was a lot of fun i had
a lot of a lot of fun doing that mate
did you what you and reggie oh so good
any pranks that stand out for you you
obviously did a few good ones
um i think you played the one with wadi
um
yeah when we managed to suck him into
not getting a flight refund or whatever
it was
um it's probably not okay to stay on
here but vince us was one when he
spoke to the doctor about his um checkup
checkup i don't know if you can put that
one up but that's probably the greatest
prank i've ever heard
the one i thought i've got it if you
want me to send it through but uh the
one where we convinced nani that he
needed to wear dreadlocks in his first
game to onomato
i i have played that one
[Laughter]
so honest he's like yeah yeah yeah i'll
do it
thanks mate
you've i think you've done a couple
others that i haven't got any um
audio on it you did a ben lam one didn't
you beef and lamb
i might have that maybe that's one that
you could send through
for good times from yeah and
rito with speedo i think these two were
a couple when i was involved
when i was over here in england but you
you came up chance with a couple of good
ones
it's amazing how gullible the boys are
straight off the bat when they first
arrived like i know
just eager to please you know like it's
just too easy it was always exciting how
you'd see the team
team named and stuff for the year and
you start writing down all the new guys
and you're like
right up first he's a mug he's a mug
he's a muggle game
this is this big list and trying to come
up with ideas of
some good memories another thing was
the nick nominate do you remember the
neck nominate video that you and reggie
did
i found that on my phone the other day
you forgot i still got it
it's blurry it was recorded a long time
ago but
oh it cracked me up again so good oh
yeah i'd really like to see it again
matt i thought that was lost to the um
the archives but yeah great stuff i
found it in the archives and i think
that was the night
reggie pranked our nutritionist ricco
remember that one
[Laughter]
these are okay to put up you've got to
put these up to the to the masters mate
they'll appreciate it oh i'm sure they
will
i i can't find that rico one either
actually but
yeah it'll be there yeah it'll be
somewhere somewhere deep deep in the
archives so then
um let's get to your caine's career
obviously your debut
that obviously went pretty well against
the sharks but
what happened then you didn't get a huge
amount of game time that first season
did yeah
you're behind a couple yeah i played a
total of two games
um obviously the debut and then a few
weeks later i played
maybe the highlanders i think um and
then i spent the rest of time
um just i mean you can get tonica on it
saying
holding tackle bags getting smashed but
really just learning just watching and
learning
and trying to soak up as much as i can
because you know it's where you want to
be so
you've got to understand the standard
and get to that level so
um still a great year like love being
around the boys and that and
at the end of that year hammer and
alarma were finishing up and buddy and
plum was starting
yeah so i had a meeting with that year
and he said
um but mate like we'd like to sign you
but we haven't seen you play enough
obviously this year so go back to itunes
cup and give it your best crack and
we'll see you end up
um and so i went back and just gave my
100
and thought i was playing pretty well
and i was like okay i might be in here
who knows who knows
and nothing had come through and richard
what was like you getting anything made
like what's going on because
what he was always on my corner yeah um
loving for that
and then uh yeah it got to the last day
on signing day i think it's it's a five
o'clock
cut off when it was like a tuesday or
thursday
and nothing had come through and i was
like right so i'm gonna have to
obviously with hawke's bay store and
have to figure out a job and everything
for next year just go with that i was
out playing golf with brendan o'connor
and it was obviously five o'clock shut
off it was maybe four or twenty
i was on the t and i get this phone call
and just want an awkward agent so
mate cain's coming through they've got
an offer can you get to hawke's bay
union offices and sign up before five
o'clock can i
get it straight away i was there within
five minutes
i was like oh thank god
but it's like it just it shows you how
like perilous to rugby
world is you know like i don't know how
many um what your
listening number's like here and and
what people think it's like for a
professional rugby players mate but at
any stage it can be taken away from you
yeah and there's there's absolutely no
job security and you know people say
like oh it's um
you know it's part of the job you get
paid megabytes we don't get paid bigger
bucks you get it right
um but you know you're you're an injury
away you're a
coaches opinion away from having no job
and no security no nothing so like
yeah it's can be quite stressful right
yeah for sure
so was that a two-year deal that you
signed no that was a wonderful
one yeah oh okay yeah but you're
impressed enough that yeah was this 2015
or so that was 2015 so roll back in 2015
and obviously
[Music]
was there and i was that was just great
because he's
a phenomenal player and he was just one
of the lads like getting it around the
boys
just super generous guys so just the the
team started to get this kind of energy
and
and um and i think thrashy
she must have had i think he had after
flying to africa
for the first game he had something in
his calf maybe like a blood cloth or
some kind of small tear
and so he he unfortunately got flying
home and and then
i got the opportunity to start the first
four games with uh
big jarrod broadhurst yeah which was
exciting so a couple of
jared's in the second row they're going
for it which was awesome
and yeah after yeah those four or five
games just actually started to come back
in but i still
was there as that kind of you know
reserved lot kind of thing yeah
and and boarding plum obviously thought
that was
played a decent enough footy so yeah
then from then i got a two-year contract
after that so that that provided that
security and it was yeah
it was um yeah it was good to have that
charity and be where i wanted to be like
i love the canes and i wanted to be a
part of it
and were you on the bench in the final i
was on the bench in the final year i
got about 10 minutes of action
and obviously you know pretty
disappointing day for the hurricanes and
hurricane supporters but
equally a fantastic day for honda's
supporters and players so
happy for them but um yeah so i didn't
get on in that game
um which was better you know there's a
bit of people to take but
the coaches have their reasons the worst
thing mate was
so i didn't play right and then we're
sitting there watching
the highlights get their medals and then
this fella walks up and taps on the
shoulders like hey mate you got to come
for a drug test
i don't even play like why are you
coming to me
absolutely and so like
i'm pretty sure it's worked out that
it's it's me
maybe i can't even else and then the
other the honda's players getting drug
tested richard buckman and brennan
edmunds two hawke's bay boys who just
absolutely gave it to me
this is rough this is rough mate oh that
is rough rough memories
that must mean tough sitting on the
bench for that whole game did you feel
like you could have added something if
they got you on
you always think you can add something
mate like in that situation like the
boys are starting to get tired you
you know if you came on like you're
going to give it a hundy
you might have to provide that a little
bit of energy to do something but you
provide energy for players around you
and you know i would have loved the
opportunity to do that but
you know yeah it wasn't to be so yeah
and a drug test
yeah get the pain in a bottle why some
fella watches me which was just
brilliant what a night
[Music]
oh but obviously the following year was
a lot more successful
talk me through your 2016 memories
all right so what we rolled in um we'd
obviously lost the final and
everyone was saying you know we've had a
big yes exodus of players we lost
conrad and mata and um
thrashy yeah and then obviously
james broadhurst had his bloody
unfortunate um concussion
um problem from itunes cup the year
before so he was he was out so
yeah we lost a lot of all blacks we lost
a lot of dips and um they were
kind of writing us off which was
disappointing and then obviously we
underfooted in the first two games got
pumped obviously
52 something against the brumby's game
one and then
lost the landers by bit game two and
then everyone's like was
worst hurricanes team ever and we we
didn't believe that obviously we we knew
we were capable of something here yeah
were you starting then
i started the first couple maybe oh i
don't know how long it lasted maybe
five yeah six games or so and then i
smoked my neck at training one day um
ran into the tongan bears hip which is
i don't recommend for anyone um
and then i spent a week trying to get
right played but i wasn't right and
didn't play very well and
not that this is a reason but like they
decided after that that
um fire and and fats would basically
yeah become the locking jeweler
and like they played phenomenally well
mate and they're a big part of the
hurricane success that year so
you know i'm not bitter about that like
i think
they were the right men for the job and
they were having phenomenal seasons and
it meant that the team went well
and so like i've always been the kind of
guy that you know team first so i'll do
whatever
i can to help the team like it's yeah
i'm not gonna
spill my milk and drop my lip and do
whatever you do so yeah
so when we got when we got to finals 40
you're on the bench again
yes i was on the bench with final um and
any nightmares about not getting on ah
i can't remember mate honestly i just
remember it being fine this week and i
just knew we were gonna win
like i just knew it i just okay i don't
know what if anyone else thinks this but
i just felt
in the second half of that season when
we when we turned it around after
listening to the chiefs at home
um and we we decided we wanted to be
a defeat like defense team a rush
defense team and like
it was pretty i don't know what the
right was like it was organic at the
start like we're just going to be a rush
team there was no like
method to it all it just started
happening and it just started becoming
this like rush defense team and like
and then when we got to the i think it
was quarter semi in a final
quarter against the chiefs like it was
just horrendous day like it was
windy rainy wellington and like i knew
that
we all know that when it's wet it's a
lot harder to attack so it's way better
to be a defensive team on those days
so obviously we dispatched the chiefs
and then the next week we had
sharks do we have the sharkies where the
sharkies there you go
that was the day yes shocking weather
that was
rough all day and i was like i was me
and kelly were living together and we're
both like
we're on here like we're just gonna do
it again
the boys got up defended squeeze them
out of the game and then
when the final came around it was pretty
much the same
it was freezing shocking that yeah
shocking windy rainy like
and i was like i've seen the forecast
from the weekends like we're on here we
we're just not losing this game like
yeah just not i just knew it so
i've had a lot of guys obviously from
the hurricanes who played in that game
on the podcast and they all say the same
thing that they
just knew they were going to win that
game i also i didn't feel the same
because i
felt the same the year before against
the land as i felt like we were just
going to win that game
um but obviously i didn't so going into
the lions game i always felt like oh i
feel like we should win it but
i'm not as confident as everyone else
who obviously
knew that we were going to win it but
obviously that confidence worked
yeah did cory jane caught that glorious
ball on the line and
scored that trial put us what 20 points
up and it was just like
see you later the game's over shut it
out i think bodies scored a
freakish try as well out of nowhere yeah
the golden one
the golden one so gifted
and the following year i'd left by then
but i think you played the british and
irish lines that yeah is that right
yeah yeah she played the line so how was
that
what was that that hey that was
phenomenal so
obviously in my four years at the keynes
four years at the cain's i was lucky
enough to see like
obviously the two finals we had at home
plus the
simian quarter i think like the cape
turnip full capacity which is
not that easy to do so like
like i experienced that stadium it was
just awesome but there's something about
the lion's eye like
running out into that field there was
fire going and like
there's that many more seats and like
new zealand fans are fantastic but
they're
pretty reserved you know but the lions
fans were just
absolutely going for it like and it just
it was the most amazing film to run onto
that field and play that game like
and obviously there was the midweek of
line so that
they've got other motivations but like
we gave it everything we could and ended
up it was a draw but
yeah the whole experience was just
something
i don't even know the lines was when i
was a kid but like it's suddenly your
dream i've made it was just
yeah it was an epic experience yeah it
looked like it looked like an awesome
occasion but that yeah you
wasn't as successful are you guys not
that got knocked out in the semis or
quarters
over in joburg i yeah so remember got
the semis and we
you know kind of lines there and we're
probably
i don't know if everyone agrees with
this but i think we probably over
trained that week
at altitude oh really and so the boys
were like david because we got the
earlier
yeah davey great man he's no good but
the boys got
we got there early and we were like
recovered really quick and like we were
um you're not feeling really good and
like
so you end up doing a little bit more
than potentially you shouldn't in the
semi-final week at altitude
yeah it's obviously we came out of the
gate strong and we were up 20 odd
to 20 months to start it was
yeah half time they're right and so it's
like here we go the canes are firing
today and then
in the second half like they started to
crawl back into it and then just start
to overtake us and then we were just gas
mate like that was the end of it
which was um yeah it was bloody
disappointing not the way
we wanted to finish and not really the
way i wanted to finish my time for canes
but
yeah how did you find playing at
altitude
it just burns a bit more like it's just
a you know you're not like heaving for
er i didn't find but like it's that it's
that like
sharp burn in your throat that like no
amount of water you drink just gets rid
of it that's what i find
oh man get the same feeling after
running a bronco like you're just like
scaling water and it's just like why are
you not putting out that fire
so so when did when did you sign for
japan must be in about
january or that year oh at the start and
what was your reason
what was your reason for the sign uh for
signing over there
i just um i wanted to experience
something new and and
travel and you know try different living
in a different country a different
culture and stuff like that and
yeah i played it right but i haven't had
the most successful
super happy career and i was like all
right time to go try something new
and obviously i played reasonably well
that year and everyone's like oh you
signed in japan too early mater i was
like
but potentially the reason i'm playing
well is because i have no stress like
because i'm
relaxed i know what i'm doing so you
know six one half dozen others so
yeah so obviously no regrets about that
because you like you did have a really
good season that year before you left
yeah i guess like i wrote down i think
i've still got
my goals i wrote before that season but
i wrote that i wanted to leave
wellington and and the canes with no
regrets
like just know that i've done the full
process and i've trained as hard as i
can i've
tried as hard as i can and if if i play
zero games or i play all the games i
know i've given it my best
to then to leave on those terms so i
felt like when i left i was like
i'm happy here happy to have given it
what i can here and what was it like
going over to japan
very new experience new country um how
was it for you
wild yeah so like obviously you know on
the speech you've had notices
there's a lot of things that are look
very different over here and it's
anyone that comes over here the faster
you can adapt
and assimilate and put your blinkers on
to agree
the faster you come to enjoy it and love
this space
yeah like there's some just
mind-boggling rules and
ways of doing things that you just you
look at it and just having me laugh to
yourself
and carry on and either conform or don't
reform no
yeah you can just play the foreign card
and people like oh he doesn't understand
you're like i don't
so yeah what are your three
favorite or worst favorite rules over
there
this is not a crazy one but this is just
one that happened to me yesterday
um i went i went to the pool to do some
swing for a bit of training
yeah i jumped in and i hit my watch i
said sweet let's go
i did one length and the guy comes up
and goes sorry mate
no watches in the pool i was like i did
it for my timing and
distance he goes use that big clock over
there
okay whatever you say so take the watch
off carry on you know
it's just like there's no reason for it
other than the fact that it's a rule and
he knows he can enforce it so he did it
it's little ones like that where you're
like this is a little bit pointless but
hey
we'll just follow it so yeah yeah for
sure
any other good ones um i have come to
enjoy how they back into car parks
oh yeah yeah everyone has to back i know
i remember getting told off the first
time i drove into the car
forwards the man ran over knocked on my
window and he's like no
reversal oh she's i just thought
everyone did i didn't know it was a rule
yeah that's crazier but well
i don't know like it looks real neat and
it makes a lot of sense because it's
safer probably to back in and then as
you're pulling out you can see where
you're going you're not going to crash
the cars
and everything but like the one that
cracks me up
is they they'll go back into the car
park
and then full knowing that they've got
to get out of the car and get something
out of the boot but they can't even get
into the boat because they're parked too
close to the other car
or like they've gone going to costco
at the boot and you're like well you
can't put your stuff in your boot can
you because you're back then
like okay it's all good
and the toilets have you found the
toilets i avoid the hole in the ground
ones
um yeah just don't do it yeah what about
the
fancy robot ones with all the squirty
things
i think i'd probably get one when i
moved back to new zealand oh yeah yeah
yeah oh it's just you know this
the seat's heated you can turn it on you
can turn off you want obviously
there's the i don't know what you call
that thing the cleaning
nozzle thing and like and then like the
whole
tap on top so you flush the toilet yeah
people understand this you flush the
toilet and then
the tap like you wash your hands into
the basin and the basin fills up to then
you know like using the next toilet
flush so it's like efficient
it's just a fisherman it's just
efficient smart that's it
oh some good memory take me back but
what about um
playing you're going over to play with
the coca-cola red sparks how was it
how is it adapting to that level of
rugby yeah so like
i think when i first turned up i was
surprised at the speed of the game the
physicality
it was less when i first arrived um yeah
you just
you'd come out of a game like knowing
you've ran around a lot but not as sore
as super rapid obviously yeah
um but i think that physicality has
slowly increased over the last
four years four seasons i've played here
and so like
they're actually starting to be some
reasonably decent-sized fellows of
in the german fair bit and like yeah you
know you play the game
after now nowadays and yeah
the skill set the boys are skillful but
it's just
it's probably the rugby knowledge and
vision and stuff like that that you just
yeah it comes from just playing touch as
a kid and yeah
you know having the freedom as a kid to
just guide it but it's very structured
over here in the way they learn
rugby so it's a little bit robotic
and what about the foreigner rule
obviously there's pretty much five
world-class
players on the field for each team at
the moment has it had a nice massive
influence
yeah for some teams for sure so like
bodhi barrett has been with his weight
in gold over here like he's played
phenomenally well for sun terry which
has been
wow it's been a pleasure to watch to be
honest but um
yeah so sometimes you roll up and you
know like uh
you have any number of international
players playing you can only play
three caps so internationally kept
players in one team and two on the field
at a time
so like for example we played kubota
bernard foley and knuckle marks were
starting and ryan crotty's on the bench
and then one will change
but the reffing
is sometimes hard to understand
over here that's a good point because
it's shocking over there
and it's it's something as a part of the
game that i mean they've got they've
spent a lot of money on the competition
now and
they've got a really good competition
but the reffing is just so
poor and i know that they are i think
the refs only get 50
new zealand dollars a game and they have
to pay for their own travel
because uh asosan was a ref
and he said that and i mean it just
makes no sense you've got to start they
got to start investing a little bit more
in the refereeing
yeah like that you know the refs are ref
and
they're doing their best out there um
and i'm not going to
gradually referee for you know for
officiating a game for
like you say not a lot of money and no
financial gain but
there's a weird phenomenon over here
whereby if you're a lower ranked team
and people who play for low-rank teams
know exactly what i'm talking about
if you play a higher ranked team like
you're just not going to get anything
like you're not going to get any calls
go your way like it's just
it's really really hard not to lose your
call sometimes
because the calls are just just not fair
yeah so like honestly we played movie
kubota this year
malcolm x got maybe seven turnovers in
the game
and maybe two of them were okay the rest
of them like
he didn't even touch the ball in a
couple and like or
the gold tackle he would literally be
touching the
penalty straight away and it's just like
because malcolm marx is good at jacklin
the refs always looking at knuckle marks
when he's jackling and it must always be
a penalty
if the ball doesn't if he doesn't get
the ball so like ah man this is
painful so you need a good reputation
and
the game's easy you're away not even
joking not even joking
jesus crazy but you another thing you
did you had your stag do over in um
japan at fukuoka
any good that was your studio
[Laughter]
what do you remember about your stag
dude i remember yo
coming in as the stag master running the
whole cutter
bloody rules here rules there you can't
point you can't talk about code you
can't do this you can't do that right
all right boss you're in charge mate
and he broke every rule and he was gone
by eight o'clock so that was
maybe it was potentially his stag not
mine
i was loving that day because he really
wanted to get you and me hammered
but he ended up being gone burger before
we'd even started
one of the groups he stitched himself up
it was great stuff but the rest of the
night was
just awesome had a couple of japanese
boys and with us there and like
i don't know if they've been on too many
stags i'm not sure if they do that over
here but
they're all dressed up as minions and
seem to have a fun old time so it's
great
yeah oh and what about what about the
plans going forward for jared
so i'm in a bit of a uh what's the right
word
a bit of flux at the moment another word
for you man hey matt you've been
impressive with your big words i
reckon there's been three or four which
i'm
questioning whether i know what they
mean or not so that's that's good from
you wrote it down before it came
back well you've got them out
but uh so yeah so cenax has decided to
downsize a bit um so i was told pretty
early on in that process that i wasn't
going to be resigned here
really wanted to stay here like really
enjoy the environment like
obviously love it here with the beach
and um golf courses everywhere
uh so that was yeah a bit of a shock to
the system and then obviously
but now it's up to the agent to find me
a a new team
and and that's been three or
yes almost four weeks now and it's a
slow process haven't
i've had a bit of interest but haven't
nothing's really come through concrete
yet so
obviously being in that situation like
it's as i said earlier like
people that you know operate outside of
rugby
don't realize that like effectively i've
just been made redundant
and if if for whatever reason a team
chooses not to pick me up then
i've got no income i haven't been
working in a career for a long period of
time like
you basically start from scratch so uh
yeah that's been a little bit stressful
recently but i think it's going to work
out for the best and
hopefully yeah maybe in the next couple
weeks i should hopefully sign up with a
new team which is good
true but as a as a japan international
surely that's
someone's going to have to pick you up
no i don't know yeah
yeah i i yeah i hope i certainly hope so
the rules have changed a little bit over
here from what i understand that
if you are eligible to play for japan
then you become effectively a local
player yeah so
that's a massive bonus for you
personally isn't it
100 yeah so so my situation is not as
bad so i'm
quite lucky in that respect there's a
lot of boys here um
you know one for example is jason emery
like he has a young family and
the same thing has happened to him but
he's not in the same boat as me so
it's just that little bit harder to to
get a gig to you know
get a contract so like it's yeah yeah
it's been tough
true man that is tough well i'm sure
the japanese club's listening to what
lad they'll all be scrambling over you
after
listening to this because they know what
a lad you are and
what an impact you would have on any
team
i wish i'd prepared something to you
know put my name out here i could like
give a little 30-second blurb about
why they need me go on
off the cuff let's hear it can do info
in two languages
uh great fatigue banter always tries
hard
you only you summed that up in seven
seconds
what a great summary but if your career
did end right now what
what would big jared do yeah that's uh
that's what i'm probably not quite sure
of yet and that's some
an avenue i need to probably explore a
lot more so in new zealand i'm really
good with
pushing pd doing personal development
outside of
rugby and like i did got a degree and
that's all good but
very little work experience so to know
what you're really qualified in is
probably
what i need to figure out and probably a
lot more like what i want to do
um it's yeah i don't really know what i
want to do yet which is
going to be something i need to figure
out because that transition from rugby
although i haven't done it i've read
enough about it to know that if if you
don't have anything
that you're passionate about it makes
that transition just that much harder
and i really don't want to be in that
situation so
uh yeah exploring exploring avenues and
whatnot but
maybe i could i thought you were going
to be a um
a bloody harness trace driver yeah well
that's still that's still the plan but
um i've got so many gigs coming up i
just
had to put that on hold
do they do that take 110 kilo fellas
apparently it doesn't make a difference
well that's what baggo says but he never
drove many winners
no he didn't well he drove our horse and
didn't really win much today
yeah oh that's how we roll
how are we one of the great horses
oh what a journey anyway jared as always
i've gone to the instagram for some
questions
and mate okay people love jared's
especially the big jared
okay first question is from chris eaton
ask him how his and allardyce first
conditioning session
coming to hawke's bay was
grant dern's run an absolute
a murderous bloody fitness session in
this
field in the middle of havelock north i
thought i handled it pretty well
but michael otherwise did not handle it
at all well
the poor fellow hadn't done probably any
fitness in a while and he'll
agree with me on this one and uh with
his crawling and
different levels of squats and all this
kind of stuff that really
loaded up the pins yeah and then mike
mikey was uh
he was like bambi on iceland he was just
like legs were locking out and he's like
oh one of the greatest memories of my
life
and you just dominated it you were sweet
i wouldn't say i dominated but i
i was okay enough to know that he was
really struggling
and enjoy it you know oh it always makes
it easier eh when you see
someone battling twice as much
oh good stuff okay this is a weird one
are you
and dane cole's brothers we're not
brothers
um but define the term brother mate
that matters 22 anyone we things are
different like
brothers i mean i'll just say like yeah
he's my brother but then he might also
say like
that actually like evo so yeah
yeah weird question okay how loose would
you get in an
nsoc do back at canterbury uni i wasn't
an engineer
so probably not quite as loose as the
engineers
themselves but i went to a few of their
barbecues and it was
it's what dreams are made of mate like
you're walking
there's like a pathway you've got to
follow around you grab your beer
you drink your beer and then you jump
back in the queue and you just keep
going round and round and round and
round and round like
and this is friday afternoon you finish
your lectures you're
18 years old this is just fantastic yeah
it was worth it
it was dark right
sounds like you had some good loose
times at um uni
next question hugh renton ask him if he
still takes the team forks home
oh get a crap hey
matt i took a few forks over right like
once or twice but i always brought him
back
i was i was actually notorious for
bringing the forks back
but uh but what it was a strange
phenomenon
in the hurricanes um kitchenette like
50 knives 50 spoons one fork and then
tony would go and buy another 50 forks
chuck him in there within a week one
fourth again like
no how does that even happen like and i
knew i was bringing my back so i don't
know who was taking that
yeah something dodgy remember i do
remember a prank
was it you who called motu about
stealing
the shoes the gym shoes
[Music]
[Laughter]
who knows where the forks went okay any
aspirations of coming back to the duck
pond darfield pond um
darfield was my original rugby club when
i was just a young fella started there
when i was i don't know four or five
five probably
um yeah do actually hold aspirations i'd
love to come back and play for darfur
great um there's actually two there's
still a lot of guys that
they're playing for the darfield senior
team that
you know i knew played with them as kids
yeah it would be it'd be awesome just to
get back there and
play again where it all started kind of
to a degree but
i don't know i might be a broken old man
by that stage but huh
kind of give it a crack you know yeah
hopefully not this year
okay this will be a good one nate valer
he always asks good ones
um what really happened to the ankle in
brisbane on the lime scooter that day
before the game versus the reds
look so rolled
one ankle um at training on the monday
and it was pretty bad and early in the
week
they would like to hold it just we won't
pay you this week
because of your ankle get it right for
next week i was like okay i'm pretty
disappointed i probably could play
so then throughout the week i've been
doing
non-member stuff so i go into the gym
and stuff to do the extra training and i
was riding down to the
gym one day on a long scooter and i like
got a bit close to the curb and the
kerbs in brisbane were just a little bit
bigger
and i kind of lost my balance and like
just went to step
off and the cognition was a bit low
and i just full just rolled the ankle
like oh then jump back on i was like
rode all the way down to the gym and got
there and it was just
like an egg was just blowing up my ankle
dan pryor is just like are you okay mate
like that it's
absolutely nuts and i was like oh i
gotta go man i gotta go back and ice
this thing up because this does not even
look what
this was my good ankle so i've gone
ahead and rolled both ankles in one word
and i've i've told a wee fever i've said
i've slipped off the curb
and wrong ankle but i was actually
riding the line scooter to the gym four
team activities but
i mean it's still a curb but yeah
yeah we didn't even get to touch on your
um sun wolves times but that was
obviously
um it sounded like a pretty loose year
like some good times to be head
on and mainly off the field it was a it
was a
awesome team to be a part of like we
when we arrived there we like
knew we were like to a degree like a
bunch of off cuts from other super rugby
teams and stuff like that yeah
and like we've gone got in and we've got
around that and like we had
some actually some really really good
rugby players there
and like had it not been for um
a lot of player rotation moving and now
with the japan squad preparation
yeah we probably would have actually
played a lot of good footy and
won quite a few games that year i
believe but yeah great team to be a part
of a lot of travel a lot of
fun times like i literally lived in a
hotel for six months didn't do my
washing once
never did dishes like it was just it was
crazy
that's scary okay two more questions
hardest player to tackle
um mike kainger
mike kainger was he he he just gave me
so many stingers i don't know what it
was
like nani is obviously immensely hard to
tackle
when he first arrived and then
you were partnered up with him yeah like
like he just gets he's just so quick you
can just move that little bit of
that space really fast so it's quite
hard to
make that tackle but and then scuds is
hard on another level like he just makes
you look like full
yeah but i used to do tackles with mike
conger after training
quite often and he's just a heavy guy
man he's just constantly giving me
stingers
so much
that's at first he's he's never come up
in that question before but it's good to
know
mike yeah just really yeah
okay last question one piece of advice
for
a person who wants to become a
professional rugby player
um don't underestimate the value of
being super
fit um that's my
kind of playing philosophy like and like
it's
i find like being fit as the team like
trains you
is good but like taking that next step
and like
doing that extra work outside of those
hours or topping up when
it's not expected of you on the assault
bike or just really
just pushing that little bit further
like i've found in my career it's just
enabled me to play like the best footy i
possibly can and like
i'm not the most talented player i know
that and i'm not the biggest
block going around but i'm fit enough i
seem to just turn up in
the right place every now and then and
do the job so like
i'll just say you don't understand the
rest of that being as fit as you
possibly can
that is great advice because the game is
so much easier when you're fit
it's such a hard game when you're
thinking about air and thinking about
how you can
get as much oxygen in your lungs as
possible
and you're if you're thinking about that
it's just too hard isn't it 100
like you also know like your skills are
just you're not fatigued you're not
tired your hands are up because you're
fit you're ready to go like
you just you don't drop balls you don't
miss tackle like as many those kind of
errors and stuff so yeah mate
if you're if you're if your career does
finish
for whatever reason earlier you could
always be one of the great mentors that
is
some of the best advice we've had on the
podcast today
get fit love it yeah
it's pretty simple mate like it's like
the other day don't over complicate
things
yeah you're a good man and absolute
legend thanks for coming on the podcast
i obviously love playing with you at the
hurricanes
loved our times together and the info
committee had some real good laughs and
um obviously coming over to japan and
living the japanese life with you over
there as well it's been
an absolute pleasure to share the rugby
career journey with you and um it's been
awesome to catch up with you and
get you on the water podcast which i've
been wanting to do for a long long time
my buddy uh based stoked to be on your
podcast um
i probably won't listen to my own
podcast uh but i'll just continue to
listen
to other boys once i've enjoyed them so
far matt
oh you're a good man appreciate it ammo
right cheers
[Music]
[Music]